our Bloomberg visual data team put
together a fantastic infographic on the
real cost of filling up and it shows
gasoline prices by the country take a
look inside my Bloomberg terminal you're
looking at the US the average price for
a gallon of gas is two dollars and
seventy four cents and ranks 52nd in the
world America needs to spend about 1.7
seven percent of their day's wages in
order to be able to buy it and all in
all Americans spend about two percent of
their income on gas I had no idea about
that very cool breakdown no it's very
cool so joining us now is the man who
broke those numbers down tom randle
sustainability deputy editor for
Bloomberg News Tom let's just start with
what surprised you most about these
findings well Gauss is cheap right now I
mean I I filled up the other day and it
was like 220 a gallon which i have i've
never thought I would see prices like
that again and that's really coming
through in the data here and I think the
one thing that surprised me is how
universally across the board prices
decline so since the oil price crash and
since round november gasoline prices
have declined in every single country we
looked at at all 61 countries the
average decline in gasoline price was
about fifteen percent so that's
something we've never seen before
usually there's local fluctuations and
price and sort of thing was interesting
too in your analysis was the countries
where gas is pretty unaffordable and we
take a look inside my Bloomberg terminal
one more time I'm looking at the most
unaffordable country and that's India
about 80% on an affordability level why
is that what does that mean well India
is a very interesting example to look at
because if you look at the price of gas
395 a gallon that's that's not that high
but in India because of their low wages
it makes it very unaffordable and you'd
have to work almost an entire day to
afford a single gallon of gasoline and
the effect that that has is a in a lot
of countries you know when you have
higher incomes you you end up consuming
more in India it's just so unaffordable
that they don't consume that much at all
so they actually spend very little of
their annual incomes on gasoline because
they just aren't driving because incomes
are so much lower as in France since is
a lot more expensive but they also make
a lot more money what's the basic
explanation for why gas prices vary so
much by country well there's there's
basically
two main levers on gasoline price one
you have taxes which in Europe and
especially northern Europe that's where
you see the really high gas prices the
seven eight dollars a gallon in Norway
or the Netherlands that's driving so
much electric vehicle adoption then on
the flip side you have subsidies and
that's what that's what you see in
countries like Venezuela where the this
year was very interesting for in
Venezuela it's it's now a tenth of a
penny per gallon gasoline you can
actually fill up you could fill up a
suburban for about five cents we should
go down there full of brake hard drive
back with some gasoline in the back yeah
I think borders control my to both
concern oh one other parts wanted to
point out in your survey be coming
summer Bloomberg terminal one more time
is to look at the income spent and South
Africa ranks the highest in terms of how
much of their income they have to spend
on gas this was also surprising to me I
know energy there is quite expensive why
is that it's a combination of relatively
low wages but they also Drive a lot so
unlike India where people don't drive
because they really can't afford it and
South Africa they drive a lot but they
also can't afford to go on gasoline very
much